they might be in game they might have to
be
well it's so good to see you the last
time we talked we hadn't seen any
episodes of icarly and now i find they
are my treats each week what has been
your favorite part of playing the adult
side of carlyshay it's been so much fun
because so many of the storylines are
storylines we could have never done in
the original series so i kind of tend to
like those the most just because it's
exciting to do something we couldn't do
before so i would say one of the
episodes that just aired it's called
girls trip that was uh one of my
favorites just because we definitely
could have never mentioned a threesome
on the old show you want hot mess brooke
for a hot messy threesome
oh i don't think let's hear the woman
out it was just fun because i like carly
and freddie's relationship and i like
and nathan so much fun to work with in
real life so we had a really good time
because our storyline was pretty much
together that entire week the fans of
icarly love freddie and carly so much
together whether it's a friendship
whether it is a potential relationship
what are your thoughts on just how
strongly the fans still feel about this
pairing i'm really surprised that the
fans are still so passionate about who
they want freddie to end up with and it
kind of cracks me up a little bit but
also you know we wrote a do right by all
the fans and i don't think that carly
and freddie are going to make a decision
or end up together anytime soon but it's
definitely really fun to do those
stories where we get to be together oh
yeah
oh
yeah
this feels so good yeah i feel like this
is such a fan question are they end game
miranda
they might be in game they might have to
be they might be we are getting a season
two which is really exciting yeah
anything's possible it's always so fun
starting a new season too because i
never even know what the story lines are
going to be so i'm waiting to find out
what crazy stuff we're going to be up to
this season it was super cool because
nathan just directed the most recent
episode that aired and you said on
instagram you've never seen him more in
his element does seeing him step behind
the camera maybe inspire you to want to
direct an episode or even ride an
episode i know you're producing right
now as well yeah i'm having a really
good time getting to produce because i'm
getting to edit for the first time which
i've never done before and it's also
really fun reading all the scripts and
even before the ideas turn into scripts
weighing in on all that so i'm really
having a good time doing that and i feel
like directing is definitely more of
nathan's thing he was amazing it was
truly awesome getting to see him do it
because i have known him since we were
little and i feel like he has such a
brain for directing and he was so
organized and so excited and coming up
with ideas for all the scenes like
adding extra things he even came up with
it was just so much fun and i know he's
gonna direct more next season
all right let's tease the finale we have
two episodes left in season one this is
going to go up hopefully right before
the finale what do you want to tell the
icarly fans about what they can expect
from this first season finale so from
the season finale there are a lot of
love interests and arcs going on with
relationships pretty much every
character on the show for the last few
episodes is in some kind of a
relationship so i would say that's the
most fun exciting thing it all is
leading up to us going on a trip
together all in relationships and a
bunch of crazy stuff is going to ensue
[Music]
you